Bencoolen you are the vice president of
the Los Angeles Log Cabin Republicans
gay Republican how do you exist there I
am I'm a Republican and I'm gay you know
being gay is only one part of me Log
Cabin Republicans exists actually to
bring the Republican Party closer on the
gay issues and kind of you know change
hearts and minds from within the
Republicans have come a long way I think
so I think there's been an evolution I
actually can come a long way but that's
because I've been eating a lot of
potassium was it difficult for you to
come out as a Republican you don't
really mention that you're a Republican
too but eventually they might reject you
and not love you well I said that's
unnatural who like makes out of you yeah
no no no friend of mine is going to be a
Republican you get out and I don't ever
want to see you again it must be kind of
hot right like you get one of these live
tarts you know and you can just pound it
out you know do you feel that the gay
rights movement has gone a little too
far I do in which ways well I think that
there are the shorts too short I think
that the gay rights movement overall has
been pushing people who are not yet
ready to you know understand what it
even is you know there's a lot of people
just don't understand two men together
they just don't get it or two women
together etc I get two women together
but not two it's like you know when it's
two girls though it's like hot right but
when it's two dudes I'm kinda like I
don't get it
when it's two girls on like I do get
things you know and I like crack open
and Mickey is homophobia okay if it
serves the free market if you walk into
a place as a gay person and you're like
I want a birthday cake and someone says
well I don't serve gay people here I
mean I think that's a pretty dick thing
to do you know yeah it's not very cool
should they be allowed to do it under
the law I tend to err on the side of now
the law shouldn't force them to have to
serve anybody they really don't want to
serve at the same time why would this
gay person want to you know get a cake
from a nasty person who you know hates
them just because they're gay hey they
make a good ass cake you're not a
believer in climate change being
man-made correct so what's the agenda of
the
climate scientists well if you're the
scientist that comes up with the idea
that then changes the way that people do
things across the entire globe does that
make you feel like you're a powerful
person you get accolades and you're
called upon in Congress to speak it's
for accolades yeah if a politician is
actively campaigning against gay rights
and you find out that that politicians
gay is it now moral to out that person
no that's something they'll just have to
live with first of all it doesn't make
them anti-gay to say I don't believe in
same-sex marriage because there's a lot
of nuances there there's a religion
there's all kinds of things to consider
it seems to me like the difference
between a person saying gay people
shouldn't be allowed to get married and
interracial couples shouldn't be allowed
to get married is negligible seems like
the same kind of bigotry well it's
really not I mean saying that marriage
which historically was intended for
procreation so a black man and a white
woman can get married and procreate two
men cannot cannot do that naturally two
women cannot do that naturally if that
is in fact the litmus test and we ought
not to allow barren women to get married
well and that's a good point I think
I've just become a conservative
checkmate no checkmate that's not how it
works as I said it first so I check make
you yeah but if I say it last before the
SD card runs out that's a good point but
actually check
[Music]